doctors in Pennsylvania are racing to
solve a deadly medical mystery they're
trying to find the source of a bacterial
infection
apparently linked to the deaths of three
babies inside a hospital our
investigative correspondent and ordinary
is looking into this Anna this is such a
scary story what is the germ and who is
at risk
so it's called Pseudomonas it's a very
common waterborne bacterium that is
often harmless but in this hospital's
neonatal intensive care unit it became
deadly hospital officials say eight
babies developed a Pseudomonas infection
at Geisinger Medical Center in Danville
that's about 50 miles north of
Harrisburg three of the infants died the
other four are doing well another is
still being treated now doctors say the
babies were vulnerable to the infection
because they were born prematurely with
weak immune systems now the hospital is
trying to make sure other patients are
safe we made sure that we increase the
chlorination of the water we've put some
special filters on the taps we have done
extra cleaning even though we didn't
find the organism on the surfaces the
hospital issued a statement saying in
part we continue to work closely with
the Pennsylvania Department of Health
and the Centers for Disease Control to
and Prevention to investigate and ensure
that proactive measures already taken
have eradicated this bacteria as well as
to prevent any additional cases
according to the CDC there are an
estimated 51,000 Pseudomonas infections
in the u.s. each year with roughly 400
deaths doctors say the bacterium should
not be a concern however for any mom
delivering a child after 32 weeks so
they're still looking for how this got
into the hospital oh no yeah that's the
most frightening of all not to know the
answer to that question and the
directing moms who may deliver early to
other regional hospitals which is a good
thing correct
Anna thank you very much